entre la espada y la pared las ong en
Afganistán se enfrentan a un gran dilema
obedecer o marcharse luego de que los
talibanes les prohibieran emplear a
mujeres
consideramos que sigue siendo imposible
para nosotros brindar servicios y
continuar nuestras actividades y no
contamos con nuestro personal femenino
en una sociedad conservadora y
patriarcal como la afgana se considera
inapropiado que una mujer hable con un
hombre que no sea un pariente cercano es
por eso que su rol es clave dentro de
una ong para que la ayuda pueda llegar a
otras mujeres y niñas
ya no se trata de su trabajo ya no se
trata de ellas se trata de las personas
que realmente necesitan servicios
también se verán afectadas y así es como
la situación empeorará cada vez más con
esta decisión
con la mitad de la población padeciendo
hambre y 3 millones de niños en riesgo
de desnutrición estas organizaciones han
sido fundamentales en Afganistán unas
1.260 de ellas operan en todo el
territorio brindando acceso a la Salud
Educación y servicios básicos a través
de miles de trabajadoras
el invierno pasado fue la ayuda
humanitaria lo que evitó una hambruna en
este país si no somos capaces de
entregar ayuda humanitaria de la misma
manera nos enfrentamos a una situación
terrible en todo el país
Afganistán que dependía casi por
completo de la ayuda ha visto su
economía al borde del colapso desde que
los talibanes volvieron al poder en
agosto de